bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rtl alors avant de parler de se
passer ni terre un mot sur la situation
des hôpitaux en belgique est ce que vous
sentez cette nouvelle vague ce variant
delta bonjour n'ont pas pas encore
il ya très très peu d'admissions dans
les hôpitaux en belgique et est très peu
de cas encore du nouveau variant donc
les chiffres sont encore très très bas
c'est peut-être cinq six
hospitalisations dans plus par rapport à
un chiffre qui est très bas donc on ne
leur semble pas encore sur le terrain en
tout cas toujours pas d'effet de se
marier contrairement à la france alors
pas de pass and i ter en belgique pour
l'instant parce que le taux vaccinale a
été jugé suffisant par le premier
ministre ace combat jik vous buviez on
vous êtes médecin la population moins
réticentes à se faire vacciner que par
exemple la population française à l'auto
vaccinale est très élevé en fait un peu
étonnamment d'ailleurs on est à plus que
80 % pour ceux qui ont su la première
dose et à 70 % pour ceux qui ont déjà
reçu les deux doses
et si on regardait plus que 65 ans les
chiffres sont au dessus de 90 %
donc c'est vraiment des autres est très
élevé alors il ya toujours quelques
vrais du temps qu'ils soient du milieu
des soignants ou des non soignants mais
avec des taux de vaccinations aussi
élevé je pense que la population a bien
adhéré à ce qui a été fait alors au
niveau médical c'est vrai que on a eu
quelques réflexions sur ce qu'on pouvait
faire pour aider les réticents en effet
après les les mesures je dirais général
notre syndicat a plaidé pour que les
médecins généralistes puissent aussi
vacciner ce qui permet peut-être d'avoir
une approche plus personnalisée entre le
médecin et le patient pour peut-être
répondre à des questions qu'on en fait
qui sont plus personnelles ou qu'on ne
trouve pas qu'on a faim pour lesquelles
on ne trouve pas réponses sur internet
on va dire
donc il ya quand même moyen d'optimiser
les modalités de vaccination pour
pouvoir
peindre l'ensemble de la population
alors finalement le premier ministre
belge évoque tout de même impasse
sanitaires pour les grands événements cd
situation sanitaire venait à se dégrader
si les indicateurs indicateurs
finalement n'était pas bon est ce que
c'est quelque chose où pourrait arriver
en belgique selon vous avoir un pass
sanitaire obligatoire voulait dire oui
oui la population ne le souhaite pas il
ya eu tout un débat pour les soignants
notamment suite à l'imposition de la
vaccination en france les professionnel
en général sont sont pour mais on sait
qu'il y aura toujours quelques quelques
réticences et donc la position du
ministre de la santé elle était
également d'attendre et d'essayer de
convaincre d'expliquer de prendre le
temps de c'est également la position du
premier ministre vis-à-vis de la
population générale
alors je rappelle enfin ma position en
tout cas personnel était que je trouvais
toujours que les mesures étaient un peu
les maisons de imposé à la population
pendant cette période était un petit peu
excessive mais j'ai toujours plaidé pour
la vaccination
c'est vrai que la vaccination est une
protection la rendre obligatoire ouvre
un vrai débat parce que la mortalité
reste quand même faible
c'est vrai que moi j'ai demandé à mon
entourage de se faire vacciner parce
qu'il ya aussi la mobilité la mobilité
ça veut dire toutes les les
complications dues à la co vite mais
keane qui ne sont pas des complications
mortelles
que ce soit les séquelles donc à long
terme au niveau digestif au niveau de
l'odorat au niveau cérébral au niveau du
sommet au niveau de l'humeur donc il ya
énormément de bonnes raisons pour se
faire vacciner
ce n'est pas que la mortalité qui
concernait un parent par ce vaccin et
c'est pour ça que je trouve que c'est
important de se faire vacciner
maintenant c'est une mortalité qui est
qui et qui n'est pas très élevé il
yad'autres d'autres pathologies
sur la face de cette terre si on
commence à faire impasse sanitaires pour
tous il y aurait peut-être des questions
à se poser
je pense que ce genre de débat doit
avoir lieu je dirais de façon très très
large au parlement et ailleurs
c'est pour ça que si la belgique ne
l'imposent pas encore je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est tout à fait vient
et qui sauvegarde un peu la liberté des
gens et qu'il est la place un débat
démocratique
la vie d'une maladie dont la mortalité
quand je disais reste quand même pas
très importantes importante certes mais
je dirais il yad'autres d'autres
pathologies aussi et le vaccin est une
très bonne protection
donc une fois qu'on vaccine la
population on peut patienter a pas
besoin d'imposer le pass sanitaires à
tout
alors vous êtes médecin se verrait sans
le sel et mondiale une frappe tout le
monde pourquoi l'union européenne
narbonne i stem pas ces mesures
anti-copie dont on voit la france et la
belgique pays voisins qui n'ont pas du
tout les mêmes mesures anti qu'ovide les
dans toutes les matières qui concerne
les matières relatives à la santé reste
très très nationale et donc ça a été
depuis toujours les matières relatives à
la santé sont du ressort des pays et est
très rarement de delà de la commission
européenne qu'elle peut être
l'efficacité de ce pass annie terre par
exemple s'il devenait à venir imposer en
france il ya certains français aller en
belgique justement où là le passé ni
ternie par an poser dans un tel contexte
quel peut être l'efficacité d'une telle
mesure
chaque pays a sa propre réglementation
pour faire simple je me suis rendu en
france et donc le la vaccination était
suffisant pour que je puisse prendre le
bateau mais par exemple la sérologie
n'était pas retenu comme étant une
preuve suffisante pour avoir le jeu on
va dire le pass annie terre donc c'était
soit une pcr soit la vaccination alors
que avoir fait la maladie peut être une
couverture suffisante et donc chaque
pays fait ses propres choix et donc même
s'il n'ya pas une harmonisation
européenne il suffit de se plier aux
règles du pays où qu'on souhaite visiter
maintenant que pourrait-on faire à
l'avenir le corps soignant générale des
médecins
donc les noms depuis toujours pour
énormément
d'harmonisation européenne que ce soit
dans le prix d'achat des médicaments
dans les les
une série de choses c'est vrai qu'il
commande se font pays par pays et nous
voyons même des difficultés
d'approvisionnement en belgique pour
certains médicaments qui n'ont rien à
voir avec l'aco vite
ce sont des problèmes qui auraient pu
être résolu au niveau européen
et c'est vrai que ce thème de la santé
maintenant qu'il ya eu cette crise
pourra peut-être être un moteur pour que
les états puissent sarthe s'accorder et
s'harmoniser entre au niveau européen
c'est peut-être ça va être le
déclencheur peut-être merci un superbe
et janick vous êtes un médecin
anesthésiste à bruxelles et merci en
tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos questions